المستقبل عندما قدمت شركة آبل بودات الهواء ،
فإن تجربتها الصوتية المذهلة
لا تصدق
أو صالحة للأكل ، لذلك هذا هو
airpod الفعلي الذي ابتلعته
أثناء نومه ، كان
براد
جوثير نائمًا سليمًا ،
كان مطور برامج ماساتشوستس في السرير مرتديًا كبسولات الهواء ، كنت أشاهده
بالفعل.  فيلم الشيء
ولكن بدلاً من هذا الشيء
، كان هذا الشيء هو الذي استيقظ في
الصباح وهو على
ما يرام حتى حاول تناول
مشروب من الماء ، لقد
تناولت جرعة كبيرة
وقد صدمتني ، لقد بدأت بالفعل في ملء
المريء.  كان
أغرب شعور بعدم القدرة على البلع ،
لقد
قام ببصقها منذ أن كانت airpod في عداد المفقودين ،
بدأ ابنه يمزح
حول النكتة ، فربما
ابتلع أبي الكبسولة الهوائية الخاصة به ، لكن عندما قاموا
بتنظيف غرفة النوم
حتى أخذوا المرتبة من السرير ، أصبح الأمر
أقل مرحًا  لتجهيز الرعاية الطبية العاجلة ،
ذهبوا إلى
حيث تم أخذ أشعة سينية
لطبيبة مشكوك فيها ، وقالت إنني سأكون ملعونًا لأنك ابتلعتها هناك ، وبالكاد كان مرئيًا للمدير.  استقرت العين
في أسفل المريء
أجرى الأطباء تنظيرًا داخليًا لإزالتها
أراد الناس أن يعرفوا هل لا يزال
يعمل الصوت بشكل مثالي ولكن
للأسف ، فإن الميكروفون
معطل بعض الشيء لذا أعتقد أنني سأكون في
السوق من أجل  جهاز airpod جديد ، تساءلت التكنولوجيا
المهووسة أيضًا
عما إذا كانت ميزة العثور على أجهزة airpods الخاصة بي
لا تزال تعمل ،
قال براد إن بطاريته قد
ماتت
إذا ضغطت على هذا الزر وخرجت تلك الصافرة
من فمي ، ربما كنت
سأصاب بنوبة قلبية
يقول براد إنه يعود إلى حالة جيدة
سماعات أذن سلكية قديمة ، على الأقل إذا ابتلعت
سماعات أذن سلكية ، فستعرف عندما تستيقظ بالإضافة إلى أنه
يمكنك حتى أن ابتلع الخيط براد
هوائه الأيمن الذي كان يرقد على وسادته
والذي يبدو أنه حوله نحو
فمه وامتصه بطريقة ما
ولكن  على الأقل ، إنه يستمتع
بميمات مثل هذه التي
تعرض صانعات بيرني في صدره ،
تلك الكبسولات الهوائية المزعجة تكون صغيرة جدًا لدرجة
أنك تريد حملها معك في
كل مكان حتى في المريء.
كان من الممكن أن يكون أسوأ
على الأقل أنهم لم يجدوا هذا الشيء
داخل صدر براد
جينييموس cnn نيويورك